and recording
now how you doing man hey good little
hungover out here in nashville
we did it up last night but i'm good
me chris porter theo is hanging out
porter's doing the early shows oh nice
he brought a bottle of tequila it was a
whole thing
oh my god yeah well i guess i'm sorry to
bring you back into this but
oh no i'm back in i'm doing a soco and
tea
ew oh it's pretty good really
yeah i had to go i went down to the bar
in the hotel and grabbed it for the for
the show
i'm doing a i'm doing a mckellen 15 here
i'm going nice
oh that's a nice scotch that's a nice
scotch
in honor i mean we say why we're
drinking on this show so this is an
honor i miss the comedy seller i think
that every day it's
in honor of alan havey uh who always
drinks mckellen at the seller
yeah and uh if you don't know alan havey
uh as the stand-up you might know him as
lou avery on mad men which is one of my
favorite shows
of all time yes he fires don draper i
mean what a [ __ ] hilarious
role great actor underrated actor good
comic too
like funny he's got some lettermans that
are killer dude i always think of that
joke of it is where he goes i got a good
wife not a perfect wife
perfect wife spy for the c.i.a yes
honey how was your day i can't talk
about it perfect
[Applause]
great joke i don't know if you can do
that joke now i don't know maybe
i mean he's an older guy so he gets away
with it i think
you're an older dude you can kind of
it's like the young
guy doing it it was like an 18 year old
comic book what the [ __ ] is this guys
right right no no he's a killer and just
like an old school dude like
again i don't know if i should say this
but like all the waitresses loved him
because he had
like that dilf kind of dad thing going
yeah and uh yeah just a cool guy from
miami
regular dude just you know like also he
also has missouri ties i believe because
yeah because i know he's a die-hard
cardinals fan so oh okay
yeah but yeah so do you have a story
behind the soco and tea or just
[ __ ] nashvilling well you know it's
the south and we're big
we're big tea people in the south and i
said what goes with a uh what goes with
a t
and they they had like an iced tea
flavored liquor and i was like i don't
want that flavored [ __ ] just give me a
tea
with some soco in it so you don't do the
flavor
it's pretty good yeah i i don't mind if
it's like infused i'll do like i love
like a jalapeno infused tequila or
something yeah i'll do that but
that works but this honey like that jack
daniel's honey i'm like
it's like syrupy sweetie yeah
i met one of my favorite basketball
players ever in milwaukee years ago
latrell sprewell you might know me
choked as coach in golden state and he
got thrown off the team it was like an
incredible story
but i was you know i'm there in a nick
sweatshirt and
the host of the show is like what
charles freewell drinks he drinks across
the street every night and i was like no
he doesn't she goes
every night he's like kenny powers in
milwaukee now wow
so we go to the bar he shows up and i
was like what does he drink
she goes he drinks honey jack oh no
so he walks in i just it was like the
most painful interaction i ever had
where i just said
he finally comes in i'm like ah latrell
i'm i'm the biggest fan i'm wearing a
[ __ ] nick sweatshirt
milwaukee like clearly i'm a fan and he
goes he goes
okay and i said can i get you a drink he
holds up his honey jack he goes i
already got one
and i said uh i'm a comedian i'm playing
across the street
uh later tonight or tomorrow night and
he goes
yeah okay and i said well if you want an
extra ticket he goes yeah don't count on
it that was my interaction with them
wow brutal and then two nights later
whatever i saw other people go up to him
and it went way worse i got off easy
yeah two nights later the last night
there the bartender from that bar that
he goes to every night was like
i heard you had a rough interaction with
spreewell he's a good guy he's a surly
drunk sometimes so she's texting him she
goes i'm at the guy's show
the comedian who you met the other night
and he and he go he just writes back
yeah
great guy hey all right
that was but like all he did was [ __ ]
insult me like it was
[Laughter]
but you left him alone and i think
that's what counts yeah yeah he took
note of that
years later he came on my msg show and i
did not bring it up
yeah that what do you think is he just a
sad guy like did his
daughter die like what do you think got
him so well i mean
all right here's one thing he's under
appreciated he was a great player but
he turned down a three-year 21 million
dollar deal at the end of his career
and he never got another deal again and
it was like a famous viral clip where he
said
uh i got kids to feed so every news
station picked it up he goes
the thing was like what are you feeding
them hummers like what are you right
what are you feeding them
so i think he caught a lot of [ __ ] for
that but i mean i loved him i thought he
was the man
he was just like yeah he [ __ ] choked
his coach and then came to the knicks
and like was awesome for us i mean when
does that ever happen when does that
ever work out
right right a fun story on that same
wavelength and i'm not going to say who
it is because i don't know if they want
this out there
but i was opening for a huge comic and
we were at a restaurant before the show
and john tuturo was eating alone at this
rest it was like a steakhouse he's
eating alone
at like 5 p.m and the headliner was like
i'm gonna go
tell john tuturo about our show and i
was like all right good luck
he walked over he goes i'm a huge fan mr
tuturo
love all your work and he goes uh-huh he
goes just saying i'm doing the arena
tonight if you want to come by
it's on me and he goes no thank you and
that was it
wow he wasn't mean he was like no thank
you
but it was super that that walk back was
so defeating it was it was like when you
you hit a gutter ball in bowling and you
have to turn around and go back to your
friends you know
notice what it looked like you'd almost
rather they're just an [ __ ] outright
because
no thank you was just such a polite
rejection you'd almost rather they're a
dick that's such a reasonable
rejection i know i know it was it was
ugly
and yeah he was polite so you couldn't
hate him you're right you just had to go
all right i guess i didn't want to come
i remember seeing he did a movie called
i think was called like american gigolo
or something i saw it with liszt and it
was one of those movies where like every
10 minutes we had to turn to each other
and be like is this the worst movie
you've ever seen
it was like it was like woody allen was
his like uh
friend in the movie and it was like you
could tell woody allen did it as a favor
like
you've done a lot of my [ __ ] you know
right holy i mean i love john turturro
but like
then you see some of these guys like
when they're like all right i'm writing
my own thing and you're like
didn't work out that's right but yeah
he's a [ __ ] legend i mean i love his
i love his acting he's
i mean great actor dude uh [ __ ] what's
that movie he did
uh the redford movie you know quiz show
quiz show
amazing one of my favorite movies ever
incredible so good in that
he's great and obviously big lebowski i
think uh
uncut gems is kind of like channeling
some tuturo whoa
yeah good call yeah the hair the face
everything no i know what you're really
saying is
a trashy jew is basically an italian
that's for yourself
i'm not gonna argue with that but
gems was [ __ ] cool i loved it i mean
a lot of people hate it i
i thought it was they're like it's too
tense i'm like yeah that's the point
they
that's that's movie making that's what
they were trying to go for it's a panic
attack
it really is it's it drove me insane i
i i was like going crazy but i mean
that's what being a degenerate gambler
is supposed to feel like i think that's
what they're going for right
yeah and they they nailed it and the
ending was a twist
and you you he was like a weird guy you
rooted for him he was like
ugly and it's kind of a shark but you
loved him
yeah cause you're just in it so deep
you're just like [ __ ] it's like it's
like being around a degenerate gambler
where you're furious at them but then
you're like i want you to win
right right yeah we saw django in the
theater
oh we did yeah in union square that that
feels like such a
i guess with covid seeing a movie in the
theater feels so old-fashioned now
yeah dude you know i just re-watched
kill bill the other night
um it's so good it's just great
it's just such a good movie where you're
like it's funny with tarantino you're
just like oh i'm
in someone someone grates hands every
step of the way
yes that's everything you want every
every
music choice every shot every line
you're like [ __ ]
i i hate when people critique tarantino
for like uh
the new one he did with brad pitt and
leonardo dicaprio they're like it's too
long and i'm like
what what else were you gonna do at that
time
right and it's so great i didn't want it
to end i loved it
i loved it i loved brad pitt's character
i love uh dicaprio was so funny when
he's drinking too much and he's like in
the trailer throwing the [ __ ] against
the wall going you got to get it
together
we've all been there so many times oh i
love the flamethrower
all that [ __ ] the dog and the the
smashing like woman's face on the uh
on the mantel i mean come on it's cold
that was crazy
yeah it's tarantino's so good where he's
like this is like just straight up
violence against women and he's getting
you in the theater cheering for it
because they're such [ __ ] hateable
characters
right right i mean they're murderers so
you're kind of like yeah this is okay to
cheer for
totally what are you watching like we do
a recommendation on this this episode
by the way before we get into the
recommendation can i try something tell
me if this works
i want to see if cause we have a theme
song from the great colin smith i'd love
to
i'd love to see if this works on the pod
bring it on baby
for sure
catch up
yes that's a hot theme for this
great theme we got to play that in the
beginning for every show i think
yeah we'll get maybe we get some
animation or some pictures of us or
something fun
yeah we got someone to do yeah we could
we could if you're watching this
and you think yeah something hit us up
because we're not good at that but uh no
yeah what like what uh what are you any
good
watches or reads or anything you've been
doing that's good lately
yeah i'm gonna throw you for a loop here
and change it up i'm i'm
gonna recommend a podcast okay i don't
know if you're into it but i i liked all
his books
and i got into the revisionist history
malcolm gladwell
oh [ __ ] you know rape pod really
takes these weird stories and weird
facts and just
delves deep into them and they're
[ __ ] fascinating
i'm gonna listen to it it's not great
first you're not the first to
turn me on and you know honestly i've
never read any of his books embarrassing
yeah i never i never jumped in but i
know he's
so well respected i gotta i gotta get in
on it i mean he's a he's just a big nerd
and he just goes deep into like
you know like a 30 30 except it'll 30
for 30 but it'll be about like
a korean pilot that that you know was a
horrible
pilot but he killed a bunch of people
it's just he finds these crazy things
and
he did want an elvis i think it's the
best one elvis had some kind of hair
trigger in his brain when he heard a
certain song he would either break out
crying
hysterically laugh and they have all
this footage of him just like in the
in the studio and they're on their 118th
take of this one song and he can't say
it without
going into some episode wow so
just he couldn't not react to music
could not react but it was a different
reaction every time
wow it's [ __ ] it's wild and they
cover the whole thing and
psychologically why he did that than
other people who have their thing
and it's really what other type of
things do people have
well a lot of it is like uh seizuring
like some people seizure when they hear
a certain thing or see a certain thing
but his was purely emotional that's so
much better than a seizure you're just
like oh
that's so [ __ ] unfair some people
have a [ __ ] seizure and elvis is just
like i really feel it
yeah but i mean he's on stage in vegas
they have audio
footage of this where he's just like
singing some song like i'll tell you
and you're like whoa he's in front of
like you know 10 000 people just weeping
it's wild and it wasn't drug related it
was just
he just something clicked you know it's
like you know if a kid's molested then
he sees a movie where a guy gets
molested he starts
you know [ __ ] or whatever it is it
was like that it was just some
some twist some malfunction man elvis
really gets
in some ways no respect like you ever at
a burger spot and they're like we have
the elvis burger and it's like peanut
butter
and bananas and banana you're like it's
just because he was fat that's what it
was
well he did die on the can which is not
a great legacy
true but a lot of people die in the can
right i feel like a lot of people
have do they [ __ ] i'm trying i was just
reading about someone who died in the
can
i'm assuming ralphie may
all right all right folks don't write in
i was just watching uh
season uh three of the sopranos where
one of the captains dies that's when
tony has to make ralph fictional
character but it was a toilet death
oh that's right that's right good call
man well he was so hateable
oh but he's so so good though yeah i
know the rules
amazing i mean run on hershberg our pal
can do like a he's got the most sopranos
knowledge and he always points out that
it's the most
character developed show of all time so
much so you know they're movie
favorites like you know their movie
choices oh dude i love what tony
tony watching like uh what's it called
the edward g
robinson movie yes the top of the world
white heat
uh white heat i love that cause it's
like oh tony's got mom issues and
right it's all [ __ ] connected
connected it's amazing you know their
preferences you know what food they like
it's that show is list hates it but it's
it's next level oh
i love joe but he's so wrong in that one
but uh i mean he's never been more wrong
i mean
yeah uh yeah i mean i remember once
seeing speaking of like
white heat and edward g robinson i miss
movie theater so much i remember going
down to the film forum
in uh tribeca and it's dude it's like
white heat in little caesar back to back
wow
i saw both those edward g robinson
movies in the theater this is like a
couple years ago i [ __ ] watched wow
yeah so great is it is it just you and
two other weirdos in there
yeah you and fred willard
and paul rubins all right [ __ ] it's been
a bad year we lost
oh we lost fred willard and jerry
stiller in the same week
i forgot about that jesus that's so
brutal
[ __ ] this year yeah i'm gonna hit you
with an interesting record yeah hit me
with you might have already seen it
but i just watched it the uh the bg's
dock
oh i loved it it was so good loved it
phil hanley hit me up and i watched it
like that
same i love [ __ ] like i watch the eagles
like i'm not even a huge eagles guy but
i just like the idea of somebody
starting from nothing and then becoming
this giant arena
cultural phenomenon yeah and they kind
of get like no respect the bee gees i
mean i know they were rich as hell
and they defined a moment but they kind
of and like
i don't know i feel like it's always
like it's like the beatles the stones
yeah the [ __ ] uh clapton blah blah
blah you know
it's that no one ever mentions the bee
gees to me is one of the greatest bands
ever
i agree and they reinvented well first
of all
uh what's his name what's the the long
haired one not barry is the hot one
yeah the other one mary was hot and then
the youngest one was really handsome and
then the two in the middle
i'm like what hideous did your mom cheat
with a [ __ ] like the alien from
american dad
what the [ __ ] happened yeah that guy
is so ugly plus they're british so the
teeth are [ __ ] up
it's a bad combo plus the long hair the
whole thing's horrible but yeah
they started as this like ballad kind of
moody
emotional guy and then they just got
into disco and
killed it i mean they like they were
huge and then dipped
and then just came back as the biggest
thing yeah it's crazy it's also
hilarious that the uh
you know the time i had like disco it's
like for black people and for gays was
this huge movement and then it's like
where is the major riot against disco
boston ah yeah of course
of course at a red sox game they're like
[ __ ] disco it's like this
that's not even the same this is
baseball exactly the same
thing i know and they made a giant flag
that said disco sucks like you had to
set worry about your team
you're worried about the [ __ ] ah
that's crazy but that's the anger when
you don't win for a while you just start
to get mad at other [ __ ]
like right red sox at that point but
later once it's like 19
like oh something i don't know whatever
1919 whatever
it was yeah you're probably just like
[ __ ] everything that was when they
that was just like drunk and anger you
know right when your team's not winning
you just start to hate like minorities
and other groups
yes yeah i always say whenever people
start
turning on the jews you're like oh
you're slipping into
some sort of insanity you know like well
the jews did the
they they killed uh you know columbus
you're like whoa
dude you're out you're out to lunch at
this point i'll give you jesus but i
will not give you columbus
that's the tough thing about being a
knicks fan it's manhattan you can't turn
on the jews you just have to be [ __ ]
you just have to hate yourself which is
right
ironically kind of jewy ah
self-loathing self-loathing but what is
that with boston
it always goes this way like cosby
america's dead pull your pants up
sweaters jello pop
rapist you know you can't you everybody
has to even out
and then boston is like blue state
or blue city whatever and then they have
all these colleges
gay marriage was legalized in
massachusetts before everywhere else
and yet homophobic racist everything
evens out
you're totally right it's like it's like
john kerry whitey bulger
right yes exactly it's like
it's like harvard southie they they have
even out right it's
completely extreme exactly it's
interesting
boston um some like the greatest
intellectuals and then some of the
most ugly racism ever yeah
crazy they they had a like gay pride
parade and they said like the
just the guys on the side like [ __ ] you
i'll kill you yo homo and all this [ __ ]
it's wild like didn't they try to do a
straight pride parade and
yeah i think that's what it was yeah i i
went to that it was actually fun
it looked good
[Laughter]
i mean the straight parade is the super
bowl monster truck we we got straight
parades i guess what yeah super bowl
boston
you [ __ ] got that that's your parade
you have you had six of them
you have [ __ ] brady for 20 years shut
up
and the socks the socks had a good run
you know celtics
the most celtic basketball franchise
ever they've got it all
bruins bruins yeah every boston being a
boston sports fan you've been spoiled
rotten right right it's true
yeah you're right harvard southie that's
a great call and they got
um i mean dude cheers just shut down the
uh
the bar they had a real bar cheers it's
over
yeah ah pandemic everything's [ __ ]
shutting down man i see a lot of comedy
clubs suffering right now but
you know oh yeah yeah we lost the big
hunt in dc and we lost dc draft house
two in d.c both great great i i had so
many great nights in the big hunt man i
mean oh yeah
that was a special place it was like so
dank and
underground and gritty i like a comedy
club that smells like piss
yes there's something about it where
you're like i don't love it in the
moment but then you think back and it
like triggers a memory and you're like
that's [ __ ] nice yeah yeah seinfeld
would say the sweaty gym
that you know i feel you go to like an
old boxing gym and it smells like
bo and spit and [ __ ] like that it's
it's it was definitely one of those
rooms yeah it was a workout room like we
worked out
[ __ ] hours in that room both oh yeah
oh yeah i can't believe they shut down
the d i didn't know the dc draft that
was closed too
i know i like that room it was just like
a box in the middle of the city
and with you know blankets on the
windows and that was a
i had some hot sets in there incredible
club like yeah that was like a kill room
for sure
yeah um i saw that the peoria jukebox is
struggling too they're doing a gofundme
hey jesus peoria uh
homer richard pryor and kennison and
kennison didn't know that
how crazy like two of the biggest are
from the same town
no [ __ ] and you know it's not like it's
new york city or chicago or something
it's [ __ ] peoria peoria yeah it's
tough it's a rough
i mean they they're it took a lot for
them to put up a richard pryor statue
like
you think you think they'd be like
richard pryor from here but instead
they're like yeah [ __ ] that guy you know
yeah that was [ __ ] that's what was so
funny about the bill burrant because
he's going off on philly's like you
[ __ ] racist you have a statue of
rocky
and you joe frazier is from here i mean
that's such
i love that that came out during the
rant because that means he was thinking
about that at some point and he was like
[ __ ] it i'm saying it
yeah oh that's [ __ ] brilliant yeah
you have one of the greatest actual
boxers
and you're celebrating i mean look i'm
not gonna act like i don't love rocky
sure but let's let's celebrate real
people too
yeah i mean milwaukee's got a fonzie
statue really
yeah yeah do you ever see the lucille
ball statue
in uh upstate they had yes it was so bad
they had to redo it
oh it was like it looked like a [ __ ]
monster
it looked like she was like she looked
like an alien you're like ugh what the
[ __ ]
wow that's great she was a [ __ ] comic
genius unbelievable and you know she
married a hispanic guy which was like
crazy for that time the whole thing's
lucille ball i heard her autobiography
is amazing
it's called laughs luck and lucy it's by
forgot his first name something
oppenheimer it's an incredible book it's
oh really yeah the the way he uh
the way he describes being like you need
almost like a
star whisperer she was so famous that
right he was kind of like she would
drive him nuts she was such a diva and i
remember he described at one point where
he was like i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i'm
it's crazy that you can have what you
think is like the hottest ticket in town
which it was it's like one of the most
successful shows ever sure is like [ __ ]
this i'm out and she was like please
don't leave if you leave
and she started crying and you're like
oh like that's how good he was she knew
that she couldn't lose him so wow yeah
it was he seemed like a good guy too but
then yeah the [ __ ] she did to fight for
i mean desolute production she made sure
he was involved in it as well and
yeah big deal to have a cuban on tv i
think it was cuban right i mean cuban
rick ricardo yeah man i mean that was
that show is so funny it's also
hilarious that vivian vance was like
this really attractive younger woman and
that was like 50s tv and she's like
you'll be married to this fat 70 year
old man
oh is that ethel is that the the
neighbors yeah she's like a legit like
she can sing
she can do she's very pretty and then
they're like
i think she was pissed to be like paired
with like an old
fat dude lucille ball
i mean you catch her in the right photos
beautiful lady she's hot dude
she was hot hot lady absolutely
i'm a fan but i used to watch that show
used to come on on saturday mornings you
know back when like tv was tv
and i would just leave it on i watched
all that [ __ ]
lucy odd couple uh mr ed
it was horrible tv but i i just watched
it because it was on
i never saw a mystery oh a horrible show
horrible i mean look the horse's
lips are moving and that that was the
whole premise oh
that's it i'd couple i like a little bit
i mean i remember like i remember just
reading the
i just wanted to know what it was i'm
not just reading the play and being like
this is [ __ ] good it holds yeah like
it's
just good writing but uh neil simon yeah
[ __ ] beast
it's crazy that that show is just like
every show
it's just like i know it's crazy like
one guy does this and the other one goes
in and you're like oh this is every show
every show but somebody had to think of
it yeah i guess it's like god and the
devil i mean that was probably the
original odd couple
you know i mean you got to start
somewhere that's actually a funny show
god and the devil
that would be funny like a family guys
type show with god the devil in
like a studio the devil is just really
messy and the guy's like he's doing that
drawing the line he's like
you keep your [ __ ] over here right
hitler's on that side of the room
yeah and devil's having orgies and [ __ ]
with you know
all these you know gay guys and women
and god's like i'm trying to read
[Laughter]
oh that's not bad that's actually decent
we might just come up with a good
animated idea or something
yeah god the devil not bad what uh
you read any good newspaper articles any
good uh
oh yeah well i had to just do one uh
this is a little older now but i had to
do one zinger i thought of for
uh ellen got covered
as we all saw yeah and she's having a
tough year by the way
yeah and i my my zinger was uh wow she
got coveted she's just getting over her
staph infection
all right i like it that's a great
monologue joke it feels like a monologue
joke yeah yeah yeah it's perfect i mean
uh
dude it's so funny that she's involved
in
like the the q anon stuff too like is
she
well yeah i mean it's like they're like
she's one of the people like part of the
pedophile
conspiracy ring is like her name is one
of the first that comes out so you're
right she can't catch a break
right i've heard she's not a great
person but also it's still
hilarious to me i mean i'm i'm in the
minority here but like
i get it you know like she's busy she's
got eight
zillion things going on so i think uh
you know
she's going to be a [ __ ] and if you
don't want to work there i don't think
you should work there i i don't know
it's a tough one
i've heard some stories that are bad oh
really yeah okay okay i've heard she's
not
she would just not have your back if you
work there oh all right all right well i
didn't know that
i've heard some writers strike [ __ ] as
well that she was not good to them so
that's my thing man like if you have
your own show you better be good to
writers
like right they're making you look good
right
yeah you're just doing your dumb little
[ __ ] dance all the time
you know yes by the way another
balancing out we talk about cosby
she's dancing happy-go-lucky cute
lesbian
and then you know isis behind the scenes
isn't that funny though too it's like
you are kind of what
the world is in the moment like in the
90s she was so brave because it's
right look you're the first this is like
a lesbian who has a sitcom like
like you're groundbreaking you're brave
then like
time goes on and they're like she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't be
on top for long enough without people
eventually turning on you anyway you
really can't
yeah that's why just the nice gooey d
level is the way to go d level celeb
that's what you want to be
we're [ __ ] we're killing that game
right now yeah we're about f we're
getting there
we're [ __ ] nice f right now but we're
like we're f on the rise
yes we're hot uh f incline i think
you're right
right what did you think of the tom
cruise rant
you know i barely looked at it but uh i
mean what he was
pissed about people not wearing masks is
that what it was
yeah yeah
he's putting i mean like here's what
i'll say about tom cruise
he's not a [ __ ] like he's he's almost
got a death wish it's weird to be that
like rich and famous and you're like
i'm jumping off the building like yeah
you have we have a guy whose whole
job that is and he's like [ __ ] that guy
yeah
so if he's taking kovitz seriously it's
not just about him i think i think with
him he's
so i'm i'm with it i'm down with tom
cruise doing that [ __ ] i think it's all
right
yeah yeah it's not like it's not
christian bale or he's just losing his
mind because he's losing his mind
i think tom cruise like you could say a
lot of [ __ ] about him but like
he's [ __ ] he's got a death wish and
he's looking out for people with kova
just follow the protocol if you got if
you're on a job you know
totally also that sounds like a mi movie
covent protocol
but also a really boring mi movie
first of all i think that rant was so
well done like not a flub
it was almost like he nailed in one take
and it sounded so tom cruisy
you do it again you're gone and uh
it was it's gonna be better than the
movie that rant was better than the
movie let's be honest
it's so true and he also you're right he
nails his [ __ ] i mean you know he
like i'm thinking now of like leonardo
dicaprio in that tarantino movie he's
looking in the mirror and he's like
you're gonna [ __ ] get them you're
gonna [ __ ] do this and he's just
camping himself up and then he goes on
set and loses his [ __ ] like
you're right he really he really is good
i mean he's a good he's good
he's a talent i mean it also gives you a
whole
real aspect or real looking to short men
short men there's no one more motivated
i mean look at kevin hart tom cruise tom
cruise is like five
six or something napoleon napoleon
complex
who apparently was like five eight which
was not that short for the time but
whatever we're on a roll complex
protocol napoleon
tom cruise yeah man uh it's weird tom
cruise had like he fell out for a while
but it's like i never stopped liking
this [ __ ]
i i mean now i he's great i liked
i think i've liked it my whole life it's
[ __ ] weird to just look at a
celebrity and be like i think i just
like that guy he's just like
you know uh what it was like his
comeback because like scientology made
him look weird for a while he had the
whole
homestay but then like the oprah couch
that was weird
yeah but no what i mean it's like risky
business and uh
born on the fourth of july rain man like
killing in the 80s top gun
yeah and then yeah what brought him back
was really good
uh maybe jerry maguire popped him back
up no it was before
all that oh okay jennifer
is like an example of a role that it's
like only he could have pulled that [ __ ]
off that's a bad movie without him
yes it really same with cuba goody like
you you get two different actors in that
in those roles that's a cheesy [ __ ]
movie
yeah it's cameron crowe it's a love
story with the little kid and the the
what's her name renee zellweger like
he's great who's coming with me
who's coming with me and you complete me
in the same yes
and show me the money can you imagine
writing you complete me in a [ __ ]
word doc you're like you complete me and
he's like that [ __ ] nailed it
that's so true yeah oh god by the way
that kid was adorable whatever happened
to him he should have been a household
name by now
i think he's like jack now i think that
happens i think you either like die
of like a cocaine overdose or you're
just a gym rat i think right right i
think he got ugly
and i think it hurt him because he was
so cute with the glasses and the hair
and i
he didn't grow up cute child stars
really get [ __ ] because
when you're a child star a lot of time
you're cute because you're like chubby
and have like a round face
and exactly a dork and then like you hit
puberty like you always see it even like
two and a half men with that kid
yes adorable and then you're like uh we
gotta skip the puberty years and then
you make it through you're like all
right he's okay again but yeah
there's a couple of years where you're
like geez and look we all went through
it we weren't sure
camera you know right right i mean
puberty is it's basically like mutation
so you're what you're witnessing a guy
like mutate into a man
in front of our eyes and it the the the
transitional period is gross the end and
the beginning is fine but that middle
it's [ __ ] terrifying
someone's gonna someone's gonna just
click that one part where you say the
transitional period is gross
and that's good
but no it's true yeah you gotta you
gotta stay hot
uh haley joel osmond kind of went went
ugly
very round head yes that was a very
round head
he's still a great actor yeah yeah dude
he had as far as gump
and and then sixth sense you're like
holy [ __ ] what a run what an agent
you had a good child agent i always want
to do a bit about like you know they
talk about like crisis actors
you know yeah like those like conspiracy
theorists will be like
those school shootings didn't happen
those were crisis actors it's the
dumbest conspiracy theory of course
where you're like uh they they were
actors but i always wanted to do a bit
it never would work
about how like that means maybe they're
like crisis actor agents
where you're like no this kid he's good
he's really he he did uh sandy hook
he did uh we're gonna try to get him at
like the next gay nightclub shooting
he's he's got the goods you gotta look
at his reel
you know shocker that bit never hit
oh that's funny yeah i don't know i
wonder how much
is that such a well-known conspiracy i
wonder if that's the problem
maybe not maybe it's like sometimes i'm
like is this [ __ ] just on twitter
or like or like some of the dumbest
websites that we read
yeah probably like i don't know anything
about q anon but apparently people are
obsessed with that [ __ ] so
i'll tell you my favorite thing about
cubanon is that if you watch the news
the uh they show them so little respect
like i was just watching
like any time you see them interviewed
on the news the uh the interviewer will
be like alright well just so you know
you are on air right now yeah right
that's how they're just like basically
telling them they're dumb
yeah and like in a professional way
they're like all right and remember
uh your face will be on tv go ahead yes
it's so disrespectful and so hilarious
yeah
i'll tell you let me tell you my
newspaper clips i didn't i didn't post
this one because i figured it wasn't
worth it but i could say
i feel like on twitter a lot of the time
for me it's not i don't find it worth it
because
people just assume the worst and i feel
like on twitter sometimes it's like a
comedy club where like
you got some people that are following
you for jokes but then it gets shared to
other people
who don't want jokes and take everything
you say seriously
completely and then i'm like yeah i
don't i don't want that i want the jokes
to be to the people that
you know yeah yeah it's a nightmare my
story was
this was it uh jocelyn know
the instagram and only fans model uh
confirmed dead from
botched butt lift surgery oh
and i was gonna write ah what an ass
[Laughter]
classic not worth it i like it
it's tough when the person just dies and
our mind goes to joke because i'm like
i'm mad at myself for like i'm like this
is someone's life they're dead yeah
in my mind i'm like same
but hey you know what i never got you
know when everybody gets offended and
all that and people are allowed to be
offended people are allowed to be upset
that's totally their right but when they
go hey you're making light of this
horrible thing you're like
do you realize how that sound yes i'm
making light of something isn't that
what we're supposed to do
like you're basically complimenting me
hey you're making light of this horrible
school shooting i'm like yes
i'm trying to get through it i mean
that's that's all we do and when you
still we still take it seriously as
humans but yeah comedians that's our job
i mean it's totally true
stan opened a great bit about that where
he just said you're making fun he goes
yeah and you're right [ __ ] making fun is
such a funny
that's such a great word to just yeah
great point you made that bad
yeah i i feel the same way like i'm not
that doesn't mean i don't i'm not like
oh that's [ __ ] horrible but there is
a part of my brain
that is like we are wired to just go to
how do we make this a joke yeah how do
we comfort ourselves how do we get
through it
i mean it's it's almost like a reaction
our defense your body hears this
horrible
sad news and we have to put it through
the ringer and make it happy again or
get some
joy out of it it's it's it's not meant
for harm at all
yeah we're not i don't that's the only
thing i always think like with dark
jokes doesn't mean you're a bad person
i've always
i've always that's your hair defense
where you're like it just means
we go to a different place to to laugh i
tell a lot of people like that who get
upset with jokes who i say i bet you'd
be surprised at how much like even
politically and socially we agree with
but
with jokes we're gonna disagree on some
[ __ ] yeah and that's
completely cool but uh it's okay like
some people are attracted to men and
some people are
attracted to women some people laugh at
dark [ __ ] some people don't i mean it's
just a personality type it's
it's the way your brain works and it's
almost like when your grandma dies and
somebody goes
well she's in a better place that's not
true
but you're making light of it you know
that's what you do
your comfort that's comforting you
that's not comforting me
exactly right we all i mean when you say
she's in a better
place i'm like okay but you know i if
you know me you know i don't believe
that
right and that's okay i'm i'ma let me be
sad that she's gone but then also if
someone makes a [ __ ] funny joke about
my dead grandma that actually might chew
me up
that's the funny thing is that exactly
if you know me a [ __ ] up joke
will make me laugh harder yes
yes exactly and you know like when
you're a kid and they go
how much does michael jackson's
underwear cost half off or whatever the
hell that joke was
you're making fun of kids getting raped
by a pop star
but it doesn't mean you're pro kid rape
right
it's just you know how you deal with it
in a weird way yeah that'd be weird
that'd be weird if you're like and also
i believe this yeah that is
that'd be good after a pedophilia joke
but also that is i do believe that
that'd be the new um
that's the new that's the new risky
comedy we were like no i am they're like
oh i'm sorry i believe that that's my
belief
right right
the butt model how about a model a
model dies from uh implants in our rear
end
uh we checked but there's no if ends or
butts
ah that's horrible forget i said it
scrapping from the record it is crazy
that a human being's dead and we're like
this is
this is our job yeah
it's true yeah i mean i think about that
sometimes with jokes and i'm just like
with like when you can see someone's
face and you can see they're kidding and
you're just like trying to have fun with
it but like sometimes
in text people are just going to assume
the worst i'm like i [ __ ] twitter
right right and i used to have a bit
about this where
sometimes somebody says a horrible thing
to you privately
and you're like oh wow i really like
this guy really trusts me
because if he said that out loud or if
he knew i would tell people he said that
i
he would get in trouble so he really
feels close to me that he can say this
horrible thing
it's a great premise yeah it's funny
it's like also
you're like this guy really trusts me
you're like well maybe he's just a
horrible person
well that too but usually you can tell
if they're
actually meaning it or if they're just
like hey dude how about this [ __ ]
crazy
totally no i mean that's why it's a
great premise i mean that's i remember
hearing you do that
once i'm being like oh that's [ __ ] i
wish i wrote that such a good angle
because it's yeah it's so true it's so
true we're
right you really are flattered
it's just [ __ ] up for them to say
something terrible and you're like oh
wow
thank you yeah exactly i didn't know we
were that close this is nice
it's a moment it's a moment are you
working on any bits right now
yeah yeah i got one that it's hitting
but i don't like the way it's hitting so
i want to
retool it but uh basically i'll talk
about how like
i go on twitter and it's just a sad off
and a complaint fest and everybody's
upset and
mad about something and i realized
that's why we like animals
if animals could complain you would
never have one in your home
because they're they're just it would be
a nightmare like the reason you have a
cat or a dog
is cause they're just sitting there i
mean you can fart in a cat's face and it
just takes it
you know or he eats the same thing every
day he's [ __ ] in a box
and if he could complain it'd be a
nightmare but he can't like if animals
had twitter
it would be horrific we wouldn't want
them
that's a great point yeah animals uh
we like them because they don't
they don't feel anything but good to us
yes i think pets do get depressed
but like sure we don't really notice i
mean oh
like a dog just greets you with the door
tag right
whaling you know waving back and forth
and you're like oh [ __ ] a [ __ ]
tail wagon got him yeah like an idiot uh
i've had a few
but uh no but a dog reaches the door
like that like i've never had a partner
like that right exactly exactly i've
never had a woman
be like oh my god you're home every time
yes yes you may get it occasionally
right but you're not going to have a dog
greets you he's always happy
and here's the problem the dog does that
because you have all the power
you feed it yeah maybe maybe that's how
we need it
maybe that's why it's such a good
relationship because you have all the
power
yeah i'm giving you the food i change
your litter i give you the shots i
neuter you i give you a house and a home
and a
you know a bed it's true and even a
horse
a horse stands up all day we give it a
carrot and a sugar cube once a year
and then you ride it you kick him in the
ribs and
we call it a nag it's the opposite of a
nag
it doesn't say anything it takes it
that's good yeah i like the idea that
like animals don't
we don't give a [ __ ] about their
feelings at all not really
no and and look if a dog starts
whimpering you're like oh [ __ ] we gotta
help it but
that's the most you'll get as a whimper
and what about planet earth
we're watching hyenas attack uh uh
antelope
and if the antelope could be like you
just gotta watch this what are you
[ __ ] nuts
come on help me here it would be way
less fun
but you can't hear him that [ __ ] that
was our ted bundy and you're just
[ __ ] watching
like nothing exactly exactly
yeah it's interesting it's also like we
don't have to care about their feelings
like you're never like
digging your head into a hamster cage
like what's wrong buddy what's going on
all right you don't have to really care
and it's so that's so nice
it's nice it's a luxury that we have
yeah it's [ __ ] i remember i had a cat
that had anxiety and like i had think it
like
evolves yeah for real i had three
roommates and i had a cat
and he would just every time i'd go on
the road he would just uh he would just
start peeing on everyone's stuff and all
my roommates hated me and i'd be like
whoa
i'd be like what do i do so i went to
the pet store and like you need to get
him an anxiety bulb and it was like 50
bucks and i'm like
cool now i have anxiety yeah it's
[ __ ]
you putting a dent in my bank account
and then and then i get the bulb it
doesn't work
like i cats will get pissed to you
they do get cats are like they're like a
woman you're like
they walk away and you're like what did
i do dude yes yes
and that's why a lot of people hate cats
because they complain more than dogs
they hiss at you they you know they piss
on [ __ ] you know it's
i can't believe your dog was dying or
your cat was diagnosed with anxiety
that's so funny like how did we how did
they know that
it was weirdly i don't know but it was
such an i mean i probably just got hosed
by this [ __ ]
pet store but uh i mean uh
no the [ __ ] up thing it was like it
was such a cool cat the cat just
it was my friend dan's cat he bartends
the cellar night you know dan oh yeah i
know
he but he uh that cat
ruled he would actually greet me at the
door he was such a friendly cat but he
was too attached
yeah so he would get pissed when i'd
leave and
oh wow it was a lot that's kind of nice
so
my my gal just got a cat so we have a
cat at the house are you serious
i was
that's a big step but i was a lot of
pushback but we got a cat
and it's a maine [ __ ] and it's huge and
it plays fetch
wow they call it the dog of cats it's
pretty wild
and i i'm you know i'm trying to be like
tough guy and you know hey i don't love
this thing and then she'll catch me like
rubbing its nose with my nose you know
i'm like [ __ ] you gotta this ruins my
whole image
oh dude cats are [ __ ] fine if you get
a good cat man
i feel like being woken up by a cat is
so much better than an alarm like
yes or just a head going like this in
your head like
gently right that's [ __ ] nice you
know yeah it's pretty gentle until
i got like a drawstring hanging off my
pajamas and it's like ah
you know that's that's tough i'll tell
you another thing about cats they just
start [ __ ]
vomiting everywhere
i didn't know i [ __ ] moved in with a
[ __ ] with a sig
this is [ __ ] brutal
just a drunk cat everyone no they're
just always vomiting the piss is a real
problem
their piss smells so [ __ ] bad yeah
it's really bad it the the [ __ ] ain't
ain't a a picnic either um but the good
times are fun
you know when it rolls on its stomach
and you get the the gut going
you rub it can't beat that now they're
fun i do like a cat
yeah it's just it's a little more
low-key than a dog
dog's a little jumping up on the
furniture and
slobbering and you know knocking the
lamp over
the cat's just kind of hanging out
i do like them the sharp nails too is
another thing where you're just like
you just have this like tiny little cat
on you and you're like oh it's a little
thing and then they dig their nails and
yes
[ __ ] switchblade what the [ __ ] is
going on i know it's wild it's wild and
then
what do you think about the declawing i
don't know they say it's inhumane right
i don't know i guess you just are
supposed to clip them yeah
i don't know i don't know enough you're
going to get them declawed no i can't do
it
yeah they say it's inhumane yeah i mean
the claws are really
i watch him like bat stuff around and
without the claws he would have no
grip he would just slip off of couches
and stuff
yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up it's weird
that like even neutering i mean i get
why you got to do it but like god it's
[ __ ] brutal that we just do that to
animals you know i know
it's crazy but again they can't complain
imagine if you got a cat neuter and he
was like what the [ __ ] you cut my balls
off
it'd be a nightmare you'd have to you'd
have to put it down
[Laughter]
if they held a grudge and just swipe
into your [ __ ] sack in the middle of
the night
not so [ __ ] fun is it right right
yeah
yeah i mean i can't complain it's why we
like it
and it's uh i think we got something
there uh what do you got all right did i
tell you the sesame street idea i had
no uh maybe a big bird with the uh
teaching kids not to be racist
oh i might have told you that all right
let me see what that's funny something
okay i got
um oh uh there's an angle i had like you
ever just pop an adderall and you just
like
uh really listen to your girlfriend you
know what i mean like
i mean like really listen it's kind of
like viagra but for a relationship
where uh you know like i even talk about
it like it's sex i'm like damn that was
that was 45 minutes that was good
oh that's good well like i'll say like
listening is a lot like sex you know you
don't try to do too much
you let them go and then uh every once
in a while you throw in a yeah
right you gotta let them know you're
still there yeah yeah
that's funny that viagra adderall is the
viagra of conversation
i think yes that's good it
keeps you it keeps you up yeah that was
like yeah
there's something about uh
i'm listening so hard baby yeah i'm
listening is like
it's funny it's also too like women
think that they want like we want they
think they want the hardest dick but
they just really want the best listening
that's a that's dead on that's great
it's like female viagra
yeah listening is what they we it's
weird where you're like oh [ __ ]
i bet they want they want but they want
a dick pic and they're like no they just
want to mm-hmm
[Laughter]
right that's great dave attell had that
great line he's like
i think women like vibrators because
they sound like they're listening ah
the king yeah the king king
but that's different that's different no
he's the best [ __ ] comic
um that's interesting it's it's true uh
they
want and they don't want you to fix the
problem either they always say that just
listen let me vent
stop trying to fix it well that's our
nature right that's like
women women want guys to listen it's
almost like when women are like i'm cold
and you give them a jacket they're like
no i just wanted to tell you i'm cold
and you're like right cool i'm [ __ ]
i'm so what an [ __ ] i am
i um exactly and i kind of want you to
stop complaining about it so i got you
the jacket it's like a win-win
we're drowning okay let's try to swim to
the top
no i just wanted you to listen to how
we're drowning
that's the bit that's funny like when
they actually need help and you're like
i'm just listening and they're like well
i'm dead now
i think there's a guy in the apartment
you grab a baseball bat no put it down i
wanted to talk about how there's a guy
in the apartment exactly you never
listen
that's funny yeah the listening is a
[ __ ] it's
i didn't realize like what and it's
tough i really have horrible
i i it's hard for me to listen i'm a
badass but also
how about you meet me halfway okay you
want me to listen
so why don't you up the uh interesting
factor
huh let me have way here if i'm gonna do
my part and listen why don't you add
some
punch lines yeah i used to have an old
bit where a woman said to me you suffer
from attention deficit disorder and i
was like if you see me suffering then
why are your stories so long
there you go old one-liner that's a good
line
also i think you had a bit about this
too like we have phones now so like you
got to beat the phone
so you better step it up or you're going
to be obsolete conversation wise
yeah i had a bit about how um like
stories i wish it worked like youtube
where you could tap the face and see how
much time was left and then of course
that got turned into a [ __ ]
fat jew or whoever uh oh really meme
yeah of course
yeah they always they always take our
bits yeah that fat [ __ ] i hate that guy
yeah he was in uncut gems i know i think
we already complained about this and
people were making fun of us because
we've done like 10 different podcasts
i think some people were saying that we
should just the podcast should just be
us doing
a different podcast every podcast
episode one
again yeah that's one
drink though i like us drinking together
because this feels like this feels like
we're actually hanging out
[Music]
this is totally old school you know yeah
i've already put down this uh
the soco and tea diet coke
oh no i got uh well i'm doing my scotch
but i'm doing a little uh watermelon
lacroix back here
that's a good back it's a nice back yeah
i would just pour that right in the
scotch maybe no this is good scotch
i'm not gonna mix it that's true that's
true is that is that a no-no sometimes
i'll put a little water and some scotch
and i can no
okay that's not do do what tastes good
to you but i don't want to like put it
i think water it's like ice you just
want to like you're just diluting it a
little
a bit but like i think with like really
good scotch i don't want to do that but
like if it's like if i'm drinking
something that's like
kind of shitty i'm like yeah i don't
care not even yeah but like
you know sometimes i look forward to
when the ice melts just a little
yes same same it cuts it a little i i'm
not a i'm not you know ernest hemingway
here
well henry would drink some soft [ __ ]
too i know he was like a badass but
really yeah he would drink like havana
libres and you know those are like
rum and cokes i think i mean oh yeah he
did he liked a cocktail
you know so i mean that's like sugary
that's sweet
yeah i don't i don't care for neat
though look i get it neat
but it just feels like you're putting
alcohol in a cup
it doesn't feel like enough for me it
depends on the on the uh
occasion you know yeah it's it's snowing
out you know it's snow out so i'll mix
it up i've reached the point of the
quarantine we're like dude last night i
made a [ __ ] margarita i threw some
grapefruit and pomegranate in my blender
bam
uh threw some tequila lime in there i
was like you know what i
put a salt rim around it every once in a
while i want to be a little [ __ ]
fancy boy
but yeah that's nice but i usually drink
scotch
or like tequila or maybe a glass of wine
but uh
i just think like yeah i think neat in
the winter is kind of nice honestly
well neat also works too and it's like
you know sam's getting married then we
all just pour a couple of neat
neat drinks and you know take it down
uh you know when it's like a celebration
speaking of that let me ask you this
it's christmas time it's holidays it's
snowing where do you stand on the
bourbon and eggnog
uh i'm fine well you don't like it i
love it i'm a huge fan of eggnog
i i can't no speaking of dave attell i
can't
i can't think of eggnog and not think of
what was he called elf come
elf come i think about that every single
time i pour an eggnog
i like i haven't had it in a while but
yeah i like throwing some well you throw
some nutmeg and cinnamon on there
and uh some bread and eggnog yeah it's
really nice i love it i love
that i mean egg you drink a cup of
eggnog you want to kill yourself
because it's just so thick and dairy and
sugary
but boy you put that bourbon in there
and it just cuts it it's perfect
yeah it's nice and i like i mean i'll
have a [ __ ] white russian too i don't
give a [ __ ]
oh yeah hell yeah it's been a while but
like i usually just stick with like the
brown stuff now but like i
this [ __ ] will give me a hangover i i
love a i love a white russian here and
there and i
i'll tell you it's even talking about it
makes me want to watch lebowski right
now
he calls it a caucasian i love it yeah
yeah i love a white rush but you can't
go too
deep in with the creamy lickers i feel
like the liqueurs
it's just too much dairy after a while
you're just yaking or [ __ ]
foam yeah you just feel [ __ ] i mean
you're like what are you gonna get
loaded off of [ __ ] milk
it's exactly like you're just gonna be a
[ __ ] you're just gonna be like out to
here you're gonna blow up yeah
it's bad news but i mean those eggnogs
are so good i end up drinking like half
a carton
are you making them at home i do i just
buy like the carton just the tall one
you know you crease it back and pour it
in like that and
oh i love it i just go out of the out of
the
carton at night yeah it's [ __ ] good
yeah it's a problem i might have to get
up we might maybe we should do next week
maybe we should get on a [ __ ]
little uh nutmeg kick
oh yeah hell i'm down that should be our
next step
yeah uh do we cover oh pet peeve what's
your pet peeve for the week
what i have wrote down something what do
i have
i wrote down a note just to make sure
oh [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] i mean this is an obvious one
but like
just health insurance in this country
man like
it makes me believe yeah because i was
on i had to
i spent like [ __ ] six hours on the
phone figuring out
health insurance apparently new york
state has some sort of thing where you
can't get a ppo
which is like uh nationwide it's like we
travel i want to get [ __ ]
you know i'm in la a lot i want to get
coverage
i want to be able to get a check about
that i want to be able to get like right
now
stuff out there so uh yeah it's
health insurance there's such pieces of
[ __ ] they all none of them
know how to do that literally every
person i talk to is like oh you have to
talk to this other person i'm like right
all right
[ __ ] you and then you talk to the
airlines right now
i want the health insurance industry to
suffer to the point where they're like
airlines now or like you call a delta
and they're like
no change fee we're happy to move it
yeah you're like good
you [ __ ] had it too good for two long
airlines i'm glad you're [ __ ]
airlines right now feel like uh they
feel like
like a hot high school kid who grew up
and got busted
yeah and and and you're like well they
got really nice and you're like no
they're broken
that's [ __ ] right why i want health
insurance to be like the airlines right
now and by that i mean
not bailed out fully and
uh yeah and broken where they have to
[ __ ]
give us some love now it's been yes
it's like cabs cabs always i know you're
a cab fan
i'm a clown guy i like cabs too because
they're right there and
it's romantic the guy's talking to you
know
dubai on a bluetooth or whatever it is
but like
i mean and you get a cab in new orleans
or where or
somewhere outside of new york and it's
like you got a call they're 45 minutes
late they smell like cigarettes the car
their seats recline they have hell and
back
and you're like what the [ __ ] were they
the only game in town then uber came in
and they were like [ __ ] we got to clean
up our act
yeah they had a meeting no more hand
grenades while you're driving yeah
yeah exactly like blaring the the
[ __ ] music
and the just the cigarette smoke and the
dirty cab and all the whole thing and
i kind of miss it the disrespect felt
real i mean
it was real i do miss it but you're i
mean i i'm
that my pet peeve of the week i was so
angry i spent like
you know i did like four [ __ ]
podcasts the other day and the rest of
the day i could just be on the phone
with tech support
and they just suck they just suck man
tech support's a nightmare then they
keep transferring you to another place
and you're like just give me the lady
give me the uh
push zero give me the correspondent
whatever you call it the operator
yeah yeah what do you how about you
what's your pet peeve
well this one's a little and look we've
all been guilty of it but it happened to
me today
and it's a real pet peeve because it's a
kind of a sign of like
i don't give a [ __ ] about you or in
consideration i go i have to be gone by
this time
and your your friend or whoever goes of
course we got you
out the door we'll say 321 out the door
you got it no problem now it's 3 20 i go
well
it's about that time they go come on one
more minute hang out another five where
you going and you're like i'm walking
away and they go what are you crazy
you're leaving i'm like i told you it's
16 times 3 21 and they they give you
[ __ ] for leaving it three weeks
are you guys drinking is that what it
was no he's sober now
i i don't want to [ __ ] on i don't want
to say who it is but like he always does
that to me and it's a huge pet peeve
yeah that's tough it's tough the person
who like you make the agree the verbal
agreement's intact
right we we have the verbal agreement
and then you say it's time for me to
leave
yes this is the time we agreed upon and
they're like come on
you got me out with this agreement right
right and it's basically saying like
[ __ ]
like look we're having so much fun i
don't want you to leave but also i don't
really give a [ __ ] about your thing
i'd rather hang out than care about your
problem that's your
you deal with that i'm still hanging out
so it's kind of inconsiderate in a way
totally it's us giving what we have and
then and
not being enough yes exactly
exactly it's feeling like nothing's
enough for that person too except
it's yeah that shit's tough where you're
just like like
i like the friends who are just like
totally like
well i'm glad you were able to come out
it's like they're not recognizing that
you did something even though
it was a lot for you to come out it's
also exactly it's also a [ __ ]
pandemic
exactly yeah yeah and that just drives
me crazy because it also makes you
realize like oh when i said 321 an hour
ago
and you were going of course you were
just lying to me you were just like oh
yeah whatever it'll shut you up
let's just keep hanging out but
i get it it's bittersweet because i want
to see the guy you're like a woman
you're like all right
one kiss and then they're like all right
and they kiss you touching your chest
you're like i said i [ __ ] kiss you
piece of [ __ ]
exactly but let's be a lot of those
ladies want to go further but
that's that's the part that's the other
part that's going to get cut from this
but no i mean you know all that like oh
no like there's a little flirtiness
there but like with this i'm like 321
that's it
meanwhile he's on the phone with his
friends he said 321 we all know what he
meant
we don't know he don't know he's asking
for 325.
we all know exactly exactly exactly
yeah no means no 321 means 4 30.
yeah but we worked it out and we're fine
and blah blah blah
but yeah that's a pet peeve yeah and i'm
with you i'm with it's
so much to even uh it's so much to even
go out
these days and like i think like i don't
have the emotional
like i'm not able to kind of socialize
at the level i was a year ago because
i'm so used to being alone now so
right now when i'm out i'm all i'm very
excited and i'm very happy to be around
people
but i also i i don't have the endurance
yeah
totally totally i mean we used to be
like pumas
and jaguars and now we're house cats
completely we've just gotten it you know
shaped or what he called uh manipulate
what's the word we've accustomed we've
been accustomed to just
home body hangout computer phone
tv and we used to be running all over
the city yeah no i totally feel that and
i think
um i was trying to do a bit about people
you ever like
like i was trying to do a bit about like
a real friendship like what real
friendship means to me and i want to do
a bit about how like
um you ever just i was facetiming a
friend
and we were just chatting and then we
both got disconnected and neither of us
called the other one back
to me that's real friendship because yes
we both
we both didn't need to like make sure
everything was okay we both just knew it
was okay we're like
conversation was over like i wrote a
whole list of to me like
i have another thing about like i have a
friend who will make plans
and i'll be like hey uh movie wednesday
and then wednesday comes around and
you're both kind of like uh i hope he
doesn't contact me and then neither of
us contact the other person like that's
a friend
yes we didn't need to check in we both
knew that we
got out of the mood it's still good
we're still okay
i don't know that to me was like it felt
real that's a bit i think that's that's
there's something there there's
something there that's funny noodle i'm
noodle with that
the only my only argument is though if
you're in the middle of something deep
and heavy and then it gets cut off
it was it was just like we've been on
the phone for a while and
no i totally agree if it's something it
if it's something deep and heavy it's
the opposite for sure right right
yeah then you're like they hang up on me
[ __ ] yeah
but no i i completely i'm with you on
that if they don't call back they don't
need to
they know you're still cool that's a
friend yeah
for sure good [ __ ] man well you're
zany's tonight
yep yep seeing the whole crew zany's
starting it feels like nashville i mean
austin where it's like things are
popping here you know the club's full
everybody's coming out theo moved here
and josh wolfe moved here jeff died
here it's like it feels like things are
cooking it really feels like other
cities are really popping comedy wise
interesting yeah i mean that's all it
takes is like i guess now with the
internet and and everything social media
you don't all need to be in new york in
l.a so
yeah it's probably good to spread it out
a little honestly i agree
i agree that way you know before we'd be
like i'm going to
i'm going to cleveland whatever and now
it's like oh i'm going to i did see this
guy get to do this club i can do this
podcast so
it's kind of nice to spread it out
you're right that's cool man
good i mean it's great um i'm in uh
i'm doing soul joel's heated dome tent
in warriorsford pa
on uh on wednesday so i'm there on
tuesday
are you there tuesday night well i was
supposed to be there on
whatever last the list was and we had to
turn back interesting yeah i've been
there already once
um i hope people come out again but
we'll see you know
yeah i think it's a heated dome i think
people are with their families they need
something to do they don't want to sit
and talk to their aunt for
three days so i think people come out
that's my pitch
don't talk to your aunt yeah yeah
come see some jokes yes hopefully it
should be pretty cool and uh
you know good show all right i hope
people i hope people are liking this i
hope they keep listening i think uh
we got a hot theme let us know what you
can do with that theme and uh
we'll keep banging these out this is fun
to do totally yeah keep commenting
like it share it tell a friend share the
link and i'm loving the comments i mean
the nice ones but yeah just like
your pet peeve or your what where do you
think you can go with that bit i got a
bunch of responses about bid ideas like
you should go
you should talk about this and i'm like
oh yeah i love it i love it i love i
love people
you know getting involved because i feel
like our listeners or our commenters are
just like they're cool we have cool
they're cool
they're funny comments i don't read all
of them but i saw someone comment about
uh a robert mitchum movie night of the
hunter and i was like oh i've never seen
that i'll check it out i love that we're
getting like rex movie right yeah
exactly yeah we got good cultured
interesting fans for the most part i
love it
uh well yeah all right well thanks for
listening and we'll be back next week
guys
happy holidays